you know how the right is about small
government and not getting government
involved in stuff unless it's absolutely
necessary well it turns out that's not
really true multiple Republicans are now
demanding hearings over DirecTV dropping
the right wing Channel Newsmax now if
you didn't hear about this what happened
is as follows companies exist that make
decisions one of those companies is
DirecTV
the David pakman show is on DirecTV
we're on a channel called Free Speech TV
I believe it's Channel 348 on DirecTV
although it might be 9415 and we're on
348 on on Dish I don't remember anyway
we're on DirecTV on Free Speech TV
DirecTV could decide we don't want Free
Speech TV anymore they could decide that
for any reason they could decide that
because Free Speech TV is left-wing or
because they don't like my face or
whatever right the DirecTV could decide
that they're a company that can make
decisions as long as those decisions are
not illegal based on some narrow
regulation that exists well DirecTV is
deciding they're going to drop news next
now why are they doing it I don't know
is it because Newsmax is right wing
maybe that would be their right is it
because people aren't watching Newsmax
on DirecTV maybe is it because they want
to replace it with Golf Channel number
seven maybe they can do that and this is
a private business making a business
decision the way Republicans always say
is what should happen
not anymore let's start with our first
clip here is Senator Rick Scott saying
we need Congressional hearings into this
by the way do you realize what's going
on with health care and climate and
education and the debt ceiling and this
is what we need Congressional hearings
about and if anyone knows how to balance
a budget it's you you were the governor
of Florida
for quite some time and so I know that
the house will house will be thankful to
have you help them with ideas I don't
ask you about this we've had about 40 of
your colleagues in the house send a
letter to a T and direct
warning of hearings and demanding to
know why conservative platforms like
ourselves are being censored and pushed
off of their off of their lineup what
would you say to that and are there
efforts in the Senate
um to try to dig into why they're
censoring conservatives
absolutely we've got to get to the
bottom of this this censorship by
companies like at T of conservative
voices what Google does what Facebook
does remember
so God
this is called the fire hose of
falsehoods it's not censorship
for companies to decide what channels
they want to carry sometimes I might
like the decisions and sometimes I might
not it is not censorship secondly we
just had a study that revealed the
claims about Google's bias are untrue
there have been studies about Facebook's
bias and it found actually conservative
political content is usually the best
performing stuff on Facebook he just
squeezed three lies into five seconds
and people watch the stuff and they go
he's probably right you know well you
watch we you know what what Elon Musk
has put out about when Twitter did this
has got to stop so we need to we need to
hold hearings here we need to get the
bottom of this I'm going to do
everything that I can they already got
rid of another conservative Network
earlier uh or sometime last year now now
Newsmax this that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to shut down our
voices and we've got to fight for this
the American public have to show up so
so if you're watching call in t say you
can call in TNT
and tell them you want news next
absolutely you can do that but
Congressional hearings using the power
of government to investigate cable
lineups satellite TV lineups Congressman
Michael Waltz says there should be
Congressional hearings as well 41
members of Congress have uh have signed
this I've got it right here a letter to
DirecTV calling uh calling on them to to
address this uh your name is on that
list uh where does that go from here
something like a you know a letter like
this uh that you send to to the uh
people that run DirecTV and ATT what
happens after that
well you know we have a number of
questions in that letter that will
demand answers for uh you know it could
go so far is to have their Executives uh
come to talk to us and explain this to
us why did you get rid of the show is it
because you don't like the look of Sean
Spicer's suits on Newsmax tell us the
truth in terms of the both the timing
and the intent uh and it could go as far
as the timing doesn't matter and the
intent doesn't matter they are free to
decide what channels to have writing
public hearings wow but I I think the uh
public hearing should be part of this
broader effort uh and and you know from
the left to essentially snap everybody
in line with their view their way of
thinking uh or you can't get access to
anything you need to actually function
as a company or a business yeah yeah
listen
um as you can tell Republicans taking
over the house has immediately put them
laser focused on the issues most
important to the American people oh wait
no it's actually not here's one more
here's Congressman Jeff Van Drew saying
uh we need to do hearings before there
aren't any conservative voices left no
question about it and it's not
self-indulgent because the bottom line
is what he means is it is self-indulgent
um what this country is about is freedom
of ideas freedom of vision which applies
to DirecTV
DirecTV has freedom of ideas to
determine what they want on their
Network DirecTV has freedom of vision to
determine how they want their Network to
play out freedom of discussion freedom
of speech and I would be angry if they
were strictly doing that to a liberal
sure you would a group of people or a
liberal you know magazine or a liberal
newspaper or anybody that represented
one side or the other the point is we
should be able to have our viewpoints
and they should be able to be expressed
in this particular case it's real
obvious something's wrong because there
are stations that are on DirecTV that
don't do as well as you there are
stations that are on DirecTV that don't
it sounds like the Republican here is
saying DirecTV should use the metrics he
thinks should be used to decide why does
DirecTV have to decide about Channel
lineups based on what is most viewed
that that's for the government to tell
DirecTV that's how you have to decide is
extraordinary overreach I can't even
continue with this nonsense because it's
so crazy listen to the bottom line of
what's going on here they claim that
they are against government regulation
they don't want government overreaching
government should stay out of stuff
unless absolutely necessary except all
of a sudden they want government to
force Twitter
to publish covid disinformation and all
of a sudden they want government to
direct the conversations and decisions
made by doctors and women in medical
settings about abortion and they want
government to decide what types of sex
are legal talk about sodomy laws here
the way Ken Paxton recently said would
be completely defensible in Texas for
Texas to do they love the free market
until the free market dumps them DirecTV
wants to dump Newsmax and they can do
that will this fix inflation no
they claim that that's a real issue
which by the way has been coming down
for months will this fix the issue of
the dead or whatever else all this stuff
um will anyone get health care as a
result of this of course not these
people are pathetic and they are
dangerous and this is the type of stuff
unfortunately many Republicans have
elected them to do they want them doing
this sort of thing it's sad but it is
not altogether surprising